j'ai environ une douzaine de personnes congelées ici
besoin d'ambulanciers
salut je suis patrick redding directeur créatif
sur gotham knights
au nom de toute l'équipe de wb games
montreal je suis
vraiment honoré de vous donner un aperçu rapide
de notre gameplay le centre elliott est
couvert de glace
quelle que soit la cause, cela est localisé
en haut,
nous allons regarder un court extrait de l'
un des crimes de méchant de gotham knight dans
une version pré-alpha
cette mission est à mi-chemin de l'
histoire de mr freeze
et nous jouons à batgirl une douzaine environ
heures après le début de la progression de son personnage
[Musique]
toutes les unités du centre elliott le soutien aérien
les
ennemis entrants ouvrent le feu sur les étages supérieurs
le soutien aérien pouvez-vous faire un vol autour du
gel est récemment revenu à gotham
avec un programme mystérieux qui consiste à
manipuler la météo pour geler
la ville
un objectif important pour les chevaliers de gotham était
que les joueurs puissent jouer tout le
jeu en solo ou en coopération de joueurs
robin a appris comment accéder au
satellite de la ligue de justice pour sho  téléportation rt-range
pendant ce temps batgirl a maîtrisé certaines
techniques plus familières
et en a développé quelques nouvelles de notre propre
montoya ici vous blesser là-bas
s'amuser un mot pour cela
juste un avertissement que l'hélicoptère a pour
ordre de tirer sur tout ce qui bouge
à l'intérieur
vos armes
la tempête s'aggrave vous devez vous
dépêcher et trouver un chemin à l'
intérieur de votre centre l'hélicoptère gcpd a rendu
cette partie facile
cela ne regarde pas le code
si quelqu'un demande je voulais faire ça
je ne dirai pas un mot les
visites étaient  toujours en cours lorsque le gel
est venu à travers
ces pauvres gens, ils n'avaient aucune
chance
gotham knights est conçu pour permettre aux joueurs d'
aborder chaque défi avec leur
style préféré
et leur construction préférée savez-vous à
quel point il fait froid
cela ne prendra qu'une seconde les
garder  occupé
[Musique]
pas de précision
euh ce n'est pas le moment le plus sûr pour prendre l'
ascenseur
tu préfères prendre les escaliers
ces câbles au sol garantis
qu'ils conduisent au gel
toujours en train de tomber nous avons besoin  d pour arrêter ça maintenant
presque là
je vois la machine météorologique prête avec le
perturbateur cette chose tire tellement de
puissance
sens que ce rusher est en place
il
charge éloignez-vous de mon moteur de tempête c'est que
ce que vous l'appelez
vous ne voulez pas être  sur le toit quand
ce perturbateur s'éteint
croyez-moi sans importance j'ai déjà ce dont
j'ai besoin
une tempête s'est levée sur le cuivre
rien ne peut
l'arrêter  affronter un
méchant comme mr freeze peut être une
proposition très différente au niveau 5 ou au
niveau 15.
et pas seulement en termes de statistiques, mais dans
les types d'attaques et de défenses qu'ils
apportent
et ce n'était qu'un bref aperçu des
chevaliers gotham nous  Je vais avoir plus à
vous montrer dans le futur
[ __ ]
[Musique]
hmm
pour voir si je pouvais
[Musique]
étranger
euh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
moi
[Musique]
nouveau
toi